mr puri welcome and uh welcome to
vladivostok we are very glad to have a
conversation with you here on rt
especially when you are the head of the
indian delegation at this forum so my
first question
is of course
the cooperation between russia and india
within your field in particular or
beyond it what are the most promising
areas in which india and russia could
expand cooperation at the moment let me
start by saying that
i'm delighted to be here
i feel particularly privileged
to be
in vladivostok
today
for this meeting of the far eastern
economic
forum
and i feel very privileged because the
forum was addressed by the prime
minister of india
and i think that the message which
resonated
in the prime minister's message which
was very well received
is that the
russian federation and india have had a
long-standing relationship which is
comprehensive
which covers so many uh areas
uh and that the prime minister in fact
personally
uh signaled his support for
uh this region and this forum when he
came here in
and i think the prime minister
specifically mentioned
that this was followed by
a delegation of chief ministers
who came here
led by our commerce and industry
minister then and the prime minister
wants to continue that cooperation and
he specifically said that he would like
to
invite a delegation of the 11 governors
of the region
to india to continue that interactive
economic process
since you're asking me about
my visit let me say
i'm not a newcomer to
russia
in my previous professional experiences
as a civil servant then
when we were on the security council
with in 2011 and 12
um i visited moscow saint petersburg
um
irkuts and i suddenly remember also a
catherine board okay so but it's my
first visit to vladivostok and
i would say that this is my first visit
out of india as minister for petroleum
and natural gas
so
against the backdrop of this very
strong strategic partnership privileged
relationship
the sector of petroleum and natural gas
which i'm now
privileged to deal with
there's really a lot of very good
ongoing cooperative work which has been
developed by our
colleagues in the last few days but it
also contains tremendous potential
i mean if i remember offhand indian
entities have invested in the
russian
energy sector something like 16 billion
or so russia has invested in india about
uh
they're about 13 14 billion dollars but
you know when you're talking about the
energy sector uh including the defense
sector and this sector 16 billion
dollars is not that much if you look at
india's overall
requirement of energy uh you know india
was a 2.89 trillion dollar economy
before the pandemic covet we're going to
be a five trillion dollar economy in
another two three four years it's a 10
trillion dollar economy in 2030 the
energy per capita consumption in india
is likely to
exponentially grow and that's not my
assessment that's the assessment of all
the
economic
and
energy entities that i had the privilege
of talking
and i think that the scope for
increasing the cooperation between the
russian federation and india is immense
uh i just give you an example india's
import dependence on both liquid
hydrocarbons and gas is about 85
in other words whilst india is making
efforts
to attract investment more exploration
in india we are today 85 dependent on
our
on imports for our requirement in both
liquid hydrocarbons and gas how much
comes from russia just by way of an
example one percent of liquid
hydrocarbons and half a percent of gas
so you've got the road map
in terms of the potential of course
these are all commercial arrangements at
the end of the day
we would want to settle both sides would
want long-term agreements which provide
predictability stability provided the
price is right but i think what makes it
possible when you have both political
commitment and the companies working
i
in the meetings i've had in the last two
days and in the interactive session
yesterday where i think perhaps you are
one of your colleagues there i did not
hear a single note
of
you know
everybody says
it's an important relationship it has
great potential and it should be work
apart from the potential what exact
steps have you taken to uh build on the
things that you were talking about here
in vladivostok i'm only two months old
so it's not what i've built but today
two uh
memorandum of understandings were signed
uh one between mazagon docks limited in
mumbai which is one of our major
shipyards and the shipyard here i'm just
these are just some arrangement
i was talking to
you know your companies
there are ongoing projects in india they
are expanding in india
and each of these companies has
ongoing projects and they are also
looking at further investment let me
give you an example for instance
projects on your coast
ongoing projects projects in india
and these are all being looked at on a
stand-alone basis because i think the
commercial operators and
backed by the government they see
potential in furthering and expanding
that cooperation
now uh
i will have to ask you this question uh
because this is something that is uh
widely discussed here in russia
some of the countries come under
pressure from the west because of
dealing with russia too much because of
building close ties with russia
is india worried about anything like
that or have you experienced any of that
do i look like a guy who comes under
pressure i mean as an individual did you
hear the statement of my prime minister
uh just now when he said i came to
vladivostok in 2009
look these are political questions these
are rhetorical questions
our relationship with the
russian people russian federation did
not the wheel was not invented now we
had a very
long-standing uh relationship even in
the time of the erstwhile soviet union
and that relationship i think continues
there are sometimes
problems of perception perception
management you perhaps sometimes think
that we are preoccupied we might think
you are preoccupied but the inherent
strength of that relationship the uh
the anchored in cooperation in so many
areas let me give you an example
uh
our defense cooperation with the united
uh with with the israel soviet union all
are preaching even of the russian
federation i myself have come here after
the um this dissolution of the east wild
soviet union when we were looking at the
original equipment manufacturers for
supplies of spares i've been here when
we india was presiding over the security
council for meetings that the fsb had in
um
in saint petersburg but more recently
sputnik
i mean india i mean i don't know how you
look at numbers but
you know by the 31st of august india had
administered
650 million doses
in in
september we're going to have another
200 million doses
brought into the market and by in
october another 300 so what 650 plus 200
plus 300
look
vaccines is one visible manifestation of
that cooperation could it be an example
for the energy sector as well
why do you think i'm giving you this
example i mean i'm a newly appointed
uh ener
i'm not energy i'm petroleum and natural
gas minister because we have separate
ministers for power and so on
but i think that this is the template we
have
you have
you know a lot of countries are coming
into production there's growth but if
you look at india's per capita
consumption it is much lower and it has
much greater
potential for exponential growth
now
no matter where you find oil where you
find gas you've got somebody has to
consume it
many of the existing markets have
reached a point of maturity where
they have their sources they have
imports
india is one country
where you cannot go wrong on the demand
assessment i would put it to you like
that and whether it's our own domestic
we are putting in 35 000 kilometers of
gas pipeline we've already got about 20
000 plus
importation as i said 85 percent were
dependent on imports so i think
those
of my friends and colleagues who have
the responsibility for decision making
will always look at india very seriously
in terms of the current uh global energy
situation of course there'll be
negotiation they will say
things which are their interests
i mean they will talk those who are
geographically proximate to us would
want to sell their proximity as an
as an additional advantage others will
say well they may have the proximity but
we have the you know
other things we can do we can invest so
i think it's a fascinating and
potentially a very
uh positive uh dialogue that we are in
with in specific projects not for me as
a minister to rep uh to recommend or to
say what commercial is happening between
company a and india and a company being
in the russian federation or the other
way around but i met i met all the
who i think are your decision maker i
had the
good fortune of meeting uh privilege of
meeting mr sechin rose knife there i met
uh
uh you know
the heads of the other entities gas from
novotech all of them and i come away
from all those meetings
and finally this plenary
uh with good
feeling of reassurance that the energy
cooperation with india which has been
ongoing i mean it's been ongoing last
few years particularly we have seen a
new uh set of coordinates in there but i
think we are
going to go much further
speaking of proximity and
the distances that could be much longer
so the work that i can see behind your
shoulder act far east policy something
that was announced act no people have
the people have concepts people have
policies but the word acted with a
capital a is there
well it says far east that's something
that was announced did you hear the
prime minister's speech he also talked
about north south exactly so that's what
i was asking what's next uh act north
act west after all russia is very vast
well all i ca all i can say is i mean i
think there was a con
comment there also that you know i think
the uh gentleman who was moderating also
said well india is not in that geography
yet the prime minister of india
mentioned that i think i take that
reference
as a sure
and a very positive pointer to india's
commitment not only to this forum to the
development of this area i mean i think
the prime minister talked about indian
technical
uh personnel and he says you have the
resources we have the uh technical
personnel and the two together make a
good confluence of course he also spoke
about the sangam or the confluence uh
where vladivostok is both you know
one geographical region joining another
realm and the coming together of country
so i think the potential does not need
to be evaluated individual projects may
need to be evaluated i mean that india
is in need of energy that the energy
sources are here that they are in india
you can cooperate both through
investments in india as elsewhere
you know when you sign a deal you will
say are you want to be 100 sure that you
have the technical evaluation on you
know
how much is the
reserves what will happen what is the
entry fee of coming in but on the other
broad thing about india and russia as
strategic partners in energy i don't
think anybody has a second opinion on
that
now uh i cannot help continuing to talk
about the the geography but before
we wrap up apart from everything that
the pandemic has done to business and
trade in the last uh one and a half
years or so what are the greatest
challenges currently for india
regionally in that regard
i know where you're headed all i can
tell you very clearly is that first of
all economic activity
in india
has revived to pre-pandemic levels
by economic activity now i'm talking
about the sectors i deal with oil and
natural gas so oil and gas i've been
answering a question parliament i said
you know
petroleum yes petrol petroleum yes
diesel we were slightly down now i have
the figures both in petrol and diesel we
have revived economically well
i
i'm not going to tell you anything new
india is geographically situated today
in a
part of the world where some
developments have taken place you heard
references to those developments
in this
you know plenary session where the heads
of state and government
of important countries who are
exchanging views on those and india is
obviously going to watch that evolving
situation uh very closely and uh
look at it both in terms of its security
situation and whatever economic fallout
there might be
who's going to be the next head of
delegation next year i hope india will
be here too
india was here the prime minister
personally came in 2019
uh this was followed by a very strong
ministerial and uh delegation led by
chief ministers that was to 2019 where
in 2021 the prime minister not only sent
me but i feel greatly privileged he told
the plenary that i'm sending my minister
so look this is a
work in progress and as i say as we go
along we develop that relationship and
i'm sure
we will continue to have a presence here
how would you rate it on a scale of one
to ten final question
rate what
the progress that you're talking about
very incredible very encouraging you see
i'll tell you if i were i was a frequent
visitor
to your beautiful country i have been to
moscow saint petersburg airports and i
remembered ekaterinburg also you know
when i used to come i don't think the
energy cooperation as a segment was part
of it at least i don't remember when i
look at it now and this must be the last
three four years
or thereabouts suddenly energy is coming
as a very big thing when i am in delhi i
met uh you have a company there uh
rosneft has a company called niyara
is an indian name but they're already
very big in terms of uh you know uh tie
up with indian entities uh their
participation and uh refinery is taking
over so it's a very good positive uh
growing relationship minister poury
thank you very much for your time and
hopefully we'll see you again soon
enough thank you or we'll see you in
india thank you very much okay thank you
you